hello everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i'll be
showing you how to add more speed dial
boxes to the opera web browser now i'm
just going to open up opera right here
it is my slowest opening internet
browser for windows but nevertheless
this is a request video so i will do
this tutorial so this is the current
opera web home page that i have and if
we just open up a new page here this is
what the opera speed dial actually looks
like now you can see it's a three by
three array of custom home pages that
you can obviously delete and add web
pages and you basically have an instant
search so that's what a lot of people
are complaining about um with us safari
for beta which i did another video about
and how it's a little bit similar but
some people um including the requested
uh the requested channel have wanted to
know how do i change the number of speed
dial boxes like i can in safari 4 beta
well here we go in order to do this go
to the help button and click about opera
because in order to do this we need to
find the file path for the opera
directory
we have it right here in the about opera
section so we're just going to highlight
this
and we're going to right click and copy
and then exit the opera web browser you
do not want to have opera running while
you perform this operation okay
then we're going to open up your vista
start menu and control v to paste and
hit enter if you do have if you have not
got vstart or the vista start menu just
if you're in xp or 98 or something else
you can simply paste that into windows
explorer so then you have this window
roaming opera opera 10 preview and this
will also work in other versions of
opera by the way and profile what we're
going to do here now is scroll down into
the button until down where it says
speed dial double click on speed dial
and it'll bring this up in a notepad
document this is is it's even going to
tell you do not add this file while
opera is running that is fine we're
going to do is go down two spaces here
and we're going to take what i put in
the description for you and copy and
paste that so i'm going to copy with
ctrl c
i'm going to paste that into this
notepad document for speed dial so now
as you can see there's a bracket size
and bracket rows equals and columns
equals go ahead and set that to whatever
you like i'm going to go as five and
have say nine columns there's something
ridiculous so you can see the changes so
before it was three by three so we're
just going to file save
then exit out of this notepad document
and windows explorer and we are done
so now whenever we open up opera such as
opera 10 alpha which i also did a video
on how to get and it'll obviously bring
us to our homepage again now i'm going
to open up speed dial
and there you go 45 home pages and that
is pretty much i mean you can put as
many as you want but i wouldn't
recommend much more than this it'll get
a little confusing but there you go you
have as many home pages as you want they
still work just as fast alright and by
the way happy uh happy pi day it's march
14th but um yeah that is how you add
more speed dial boxes to the opera web
browser so thank you for the request and
i hope you enjoyed this tutorial if you
have any other tutorial ideas or
requests just go ahead and send a uh
first you all you have to subscribe and
then go ahead and send a request and i
will try to get to it so thanks for
watching this one and peace